previously on TV sense if this doesn't
work I might just have my stomach
stapled and just be done with hmm keep
looking shocked and moved slowly towards
the cake
starting your story at a crossroads
cliche there are always shots like this
in zombie apocalypse movies of abandoned
cars and people dead in them but what
did this woman die out she run out of
gas and decided to sit in place until
she starved to death
seriously Rick had to get this enclosed
to see the sign that indicated no gas if
he's this nearsighted should he really
be in law enforcement since this is
obviously a zombie child why is she
picking up this teddy bear like it's
important to her one of the show's
biggest weaknesses is that it can't
stick to any given set of rules for the
debt because it's more concerned with
setting up a lame fake out the same sick
mind you chill [ __ ] about a global
warming I realized the show was
immediately setting up policemen
Punisher here to be an [ __ ] but
here's Rick laughing along and casually
also misogyny are we really supposed to
be rooting for him you are still too
damn stupid to learn how to turn off a
switch Joe at the go the polite version
there's why this dialogue was written by
an alien race that read a book written
by a different alien race that was
titled how earth dudes interact I think
I was the most close mess son of a [ __ ]
ever hear her tally I really wish there
were more clothes mounts in the scene
and a lot more Walking Dead last thing
she said this morning sometimes I wonder
if you even care about us at all dear
God we're now entering minute for these
two men complaining about the women in
their lives started to wonder if we were
meant to end up on Team Walker these two
patrol vehicles completely switch lanes
on a solid yellow at high speed to avoid
roadkill safety first officers safety
first
damn didn't Rick and Shane give the
pursuing officers a heads-up about where
the spikes were they ran right into that
those guys have been dead I guess we can
call it a day then hey guys with at
least eight officers all shooting and
missing this maniac this long I think
it's safe to say the King County
Sheriff's Office trains at the
Stormtrooper Academy of aiming at things
and this is why actual law enforcement
officers secure a scene before engaging
in off-the-cuff conversations about
bulletproof vests and such kind of feels
like Rick deserves what's coming here
also none of the other half dozen cops
with guns saw this guy neither seriously
did they call in reinforcements from
nearby Keystone Georgia on this oh nice
of Shane to try and help but Rick was
shot in the back so shouldn't he be
applying pressure at the source of the
wound sure we're all a little distracted
right now but he's definitely been
trained in basic in first-aid
cutting-edge sho somehow uses an effect
from a 1970s soap opera during a coma
scene I guess since they couldn't zombie
too much in the first part of the pilot
they had to resort to nauseating the
audience in other ways I would give
every cent back if the show would pull a
De Palma split screen out of Cillian
Murphy waking up in the UK why is the
clock stopped at the exact same time to
the exact second as the clock and Rick's
hospital room this would make sense if
these clocks ran on electricity but
these are battery operated models and it
would be almost impossible that the
batteries would die at the same time in
fact considering wall clock batteries
can last up to a year it's unlikely that
both would have run out of batteries at
all
now's as good a time as any to try and
figure out how this show wants us to
believe this time line went down
obviously it had to be a fairly quick
thing since Rick didn't die of
dehydration which is usually about a
two-week process but the level of
destruction in this place looks like
it's been falling apart for months not
to mention if you had time to trap the
dead in the cafeteria and spray paint
don't open dead inside wouldn't you also
have time to move the patients out of
the hospital to somewhere safe all of
which points to one of the biggest
weaknesses in the show's logic which is
that somehow we couldn't contain an
outbreak that relies not only on
physical contact but actually fighting
and even then takes time to manifest I
mean come on we'd have that done locked
down within the first week America yeah
also would it be nice if they did a
spin-off some day about the start of the
SPOC ellipse to answer some of these
questions but instead of really fleshing
out the origins it just devolved into
the same exact show as this one within
the first few episodes now would never
happen also also couldn't you easily
read this as don't dead open inside and
wouldn't that lead you to think that to
not die you need to open the door to the
inside I don't know man I just think if
this person was clever enough to lock
the zombies in here and write a warning
it could have been much clearer this
hospital gown is supposed to be the
other way right did the orderly he put
it on him have a contrarian streak or
was he or she just a huge criss-cross
fan okay I promise this is the last time
I'll ask but how the hell does all this
happen including a giant hole in the
side of the building and Rick just sits
in his room untouched this is the world
that feels at least a year into its
apocalypse not a few weeks whoa did
anyone remember there was a goddamn
helicopter here and like it doesn't even
look damaged
sure Rick's gonna try and find his
family first but overall this is
immediately forgotten in this series
like priority one fine family priority
to find a goddamn helicopter pilot you
could fly to [ __ ] Hill met the
scooching dead also damn she's already
ripped in half dude you also have to
steal her bike instead of using the
perfectly functional revolver that I
just pointed at you a few minutes ago
you shot him in the street out front a
man trained uniquely Isis it was a walk
a walker a so is this some alternate
universe where George Romero never
existed no zombie comics no zombie
movies nothing cuz there was no way if
this ever happened that every single
person wouldn't be calling these things
a'm beets and the fact that no one in
this show actually does is pure lunacy
cuz he didn't
in the you try to eat you take uh some
flesh at least this conversation
couldn't have waited until after dinner
bites kill yeah the fever buns yeah good
thing Basile exposition or he'd be a
zombie snack by now once again mombi
seems to be going against established
rules to make a dramatic point every
single one of these things should just
be headed towards that car alarm if you
wanted them to haunt the places they
used to live you should have gone with
ghosts instead man taking a bat to a
walker is brutal but I guess that's the
world they live in now can you imagine
if it was the kind of show that would do
this kind of thing to a living character
like when we've grown to love and care
about over several seasons my wife and
son they packed some clothes not alive
but enough to travel you know anybody
could have broke in here and stolen
clothes right Morgan would be excellent
at TV since Cena for Disease Control
said they were working out how to solve
this thing man I'm excited this show
will be about finding a cure to this
thing since that would be much more
interesting than spending about 75
episodes on a farm or a parade of
progressively psychotic antagonists for
sure with this much potential did
something like that I can't imagine how
many sins I'd have to give it maybe
twenty I actually like this kid can we
team him up with Grimes and just have
them travel around new world solving
problems maybe call it Rick and Shorty
Scott why hasn't all of it gone missing
Rick was the only cop in the town I
think to grab some guns before heading
out see anyway nope
exactly how much louder is a gun shot
than these full hammer swings I mean I
know guns are louder but shouldn't this
still be a level of noise that they
should be concerned about oh yeah I
remember that desperate search for
Rick's family we're gonna pause that so
he can track down and properly retire
half lady classic Rick I do like how
this show focuses on the personal
struggle of the survivors and not just
the dead but I swear to God if I hear
one more person pompously remind me the
show's title is actually about the
remaining humans and not the zombies I'm
getting Lucille in fact here's an extra
thirty sins for each time someone's
brought it up anybody reads please
respond hello hello is a person who
called still in the air driving miles
from this town and the one group that
hears him includes not only people he's
met but his actual partner on the force
his wife and his son that's some
next-level conveniency right there folks
this is officer Shane Walsh broadcasting
a person unknown please respond he's
gonna holy Shane I know patience isn't
your strong suit as evidenced by you
immediately nailing your partner's wife
but the person is clearly there it's
just some [ __ ] bad reception man they
don't have time to put signs up warning
people to stay out of the city but
they've got time for
this no one will be allowed to change
channels during part two of the Rick
Grimes holds a gas can and slowly walks
down the street portion of the episode
keys are in the ignition click keys or
another Sun Visor um guy somehow finds
all ways to ride cliche not gonna hurt
you nothing like that more like a
proposal Jesus Rick I know it's been a
few days without a woman around but this
really is a spectacular shot and all but
come on not a single car is on the
highway into town I'm not suggesting
anyone should be driving in that
direction I'm suggesting that in an
extreme situation like this at least one
[ __ ] says screw the rules I'm driving
down the exit ramp and getting out of
this nightmare
I'm also suggesting that I'm definitely
that [ __ ] hey there's another
helicopter that looks perfectly
functional if you've got gas for cars
why not fire that girl god damn the
pilotless helicopters in this pilot
really pissed me off to be fair these
zombies stole we had the right away
Gloria Carl I'm sorry this scene turned
so quickly due to Rick somehow not
previously seeing the open hatch right
in front of his face then I'm gonna sue
Frank Darabont for whiplash how is it
even remotely possible to relax around
any corpse at this point oh please not
to eat a dead horse here but the zombies
take naps now seriously allow and creaky
metal didn't wake him when Rick closed
the hatch
she'll obviously favors dramatic tension
over world consistency and we don't
stand for that around here not by the
hair of our city Simpsons
the big brain on a brass Ricky the
doctor told us that we should let you
work it out in your own sweet time but
Ricky you can walk
[Music]
[Music]
and who the hell would you propose we
send
[Music]
and for me to left on 84 and then what
did you hear it sounded like a cocktail
party